I'm on team wash your chicken before cooking.
Although many feel you should not wash your chicken,
I'm starting with a fully pasture raised chicken from my parents farm
that was slaughtered at 3 months of age
right there on the farm in a healthy farm environment.
After washing and preparing the poultry,
I clean my work surfaces
tools in the surrounding area with branch basics.
A superior
non toxic cleaning product that's not only free of harmful chemicals,
it's also cheaper. Well,
it can't get any healthier than this bird,
but still, I feel more comfortable washing my chicken.
I prefer to start with a clean slate,
free of debris, filament,
or whatever may be left over on the meat
from the slaughtering and processing.
I always wash my meats and my fish too.
I also rinse my legumes, rice and nuts before cooking.
And if you're wondering, I get 64 laundry loads
plus 14 bottles of home and kitchen cleaning products
out of one bottle of Branch Basics concentrate. Alright.
And this is peach chicken.
Insane, I tell you.